Générique
...
*-Envoyez.
-Tous les départs se ressemblent
ou celui-ci a un goût particulier
pour vous ?
-C'est toujours un moment
à la fois d'excitation
et d'appréhension aussi.
L'équipage apprend à se connaître
depuis l'été et le rotary.
-On se lève toujours
aussi tôt dans la marine ?
-On aime bien faire les choses tôt.
Et le travail de nuit est
une des particularités du travail.
Et voir l'aube comme ça à Brest,
ça reste un plaisir.
Musique douce
-Les marins disent que même
le plus petit de leur bateau
est un bout de France en mer.
...
On a beau être un marin confirmé,
l'appareillage d'une frégate
a un air de rituel.
...
-D'abord, on va se décoller
en mettant à gauche toute.
Tribord avant 0
et la RT à contre.
Donc 180,
30 %.
L'idée est de viser une position
à à peu près 10 m du quai
pour garder suffisamment
d'eau sur tribord.
...
-2 machines avant 0.
Brouhaha et propos indistincts
...
-Paré à manoeuvrer.
-L'Aquitaine est un fer de lance
de la marine française.
Ces nouvelles frégates
sont considérées
comme les plus importants
bâtiments de surface
d'une flotte de guerre.
A bord,
une centaine de membres d'équipage,
des marins formés aux équipements
de dernière génération.
-292.
Bip
*-Reçu.
-Pompes de barre numéro 2
de chaque bord arrêtées.
Pompes de barre numéro 1
en fonction.
A la base,
je suis secrétaire-commandant.
Je monte dans les tours de quart
à la barre
pour soulager les manoeuvriers
et leur donner de l'aide.
-Là, en soi,
vous pilotez le bateau ?
-Oui, sous les ordres
du chef du quart.
Le cap qu'il m'a donné, par exemple,
c'est le 267.
Moi, j'essaie de tenir
au mieux le cap 267,
en donnant des angles de barre
à gauche et droite avec le joystick.
-Le fait que tout soit automatisé,
c'est un confort de travail ?
-Oui, c'est un confort de travail.
Je peux rester tout un quart
en garde-route et juste,
seulement si le cap change,
changer avec mon joystick.
Après, le fait d'être en manuel,
ça fait passer le temps plus vite.
Donc ça dépend des fois.
-Vous avez quand même une belle vue.
-Là, il y a une belle vue.
C'est un quart plutôt agréable.
-Vous pouvez prévenir.
On réduit en allure et on déploie...
-Cette semaine, l'équipage subira
une série d'évaluations,
une remise à niveau opérationnelle.
C'est incontournable
pour partir en mission.
Et selon les marins,
les tensions en mer
n'ont jamais été aussi élevées.
-La mer est un milieu fluide,
dans lequel
on peut circuler librement.
Aujourd'hui, sur les bâtiments
de la marine nationale,
nous croisons très régulièrement
nos compétiteurs.
Donc la situation,
qui est assez instable en ce moment,
peut à tout moment basculer
d'un côté ou de l'autre.
Comme le dit
le chef d'état-major de la marine :
"En mer, sur un bâtiment
de la marine nationale,
"le temps de crise
et le temps de guerre
"ne tiennent qu'aux ordres
qu'on reçoit."
-Comment est la barre ?
*-5 à gauche.
-5 à gauche.
-Ce qui est certain,
c'est que tous les grands pays
et les grandes puissances du monde
réarment leur marine
à une vitesse assez importante.
Tant en quantité qu'en qualité.
Ensuite, on voit bien
que la mer est aussi
l'espace par lequel transitent
toutes les richesses
et tout le commerce mondial.
Egalement, sous les mers
transitent les fameux câbles
dont on entend souvent parler,
par lesquels transitent
toutes les informations Internet
qui peuvent susciter
beaucoup de convoitise.
-Je préviens la machine.
-Oui, ils vous servent
juste à tenir.
Si le bateau bouge pas trop.
-On laisse comme ça.
-Si ça part d'un bord ou l'autre,
vous contrez.
Donc on reste comme ça.
-Reçu, commandant.
-Vous allez pouvoir aller
au fond du couloir.
On va arriver
dans la coursive commandant.
-La frégate est un navire de guerre
pouvant répondre
à toutes les missions de combat.
Sur l'échiquier naval,
c'est une pièce clé du grand large.
A en croire les marins,
elle est taillée
pour les chocs les plus durs.
-Attention,
la porte est un peu compliquée.
C'est bon, elle est bloquée.
On arrive sur le roof VLS.
C'est d'ici que vont partir
les différents missiles.
Il y en a de plusieurs types.
Il y a les asters et les MdCN.
Les asters permettent de faire
de la lutte anti-aérienne,
de traiter une menace qui arrive.
Que ce soit directement un avion,
un hélicoptère,
ou toute menace aérienne.
Le MdCN, lui,
il sert à faire
des frappes contre terre.
C'est des missiles qui sont tirés
depuis la mer jusqu'à la terre.
Ils ont une portée importante.
Ils vont nous permettre,
par exemple,
de frapper un point
à une distance assez importante.
Ils vont nous donner
un avantage sur l'ennemi.
On peut rester en sécurité
tout en pouvant le frapper.
-Actuellement,
quand on est en exercice,
comme maintenant,
est-ce qu'on emporte
des munitions réelles ?
-On en emporte toujours,
puisque même si on est en exercice
et si on s'entraîne, on est
toujours susceptibles de basculer
directement sur une opération.
Surtout en ce moment,
avec des niveaux de crise
un peu partout dans le monde.
Il faut pouvoir réagir très vite.
D'autant plus qu'en entraînement,
on est toujours aussi en mission.
On fait du renseignement
ou d'autres missions.
Musique calme
*Propos indistincts
...
-Remise de gaz.
*-Remise de gaz.
...
-Une frégate en exercice embarque
des entraîneurs,
des marins aguerris,
envoyés par l'état-major.
Aujourd'hui,
ces hommes au brassard jaune
ont écrit un scénario
proche du réel.
Le décor : un navire suspect.
Les personnages :
des marins armés jusqu'aux dents.
-2 machines avant 1.
En anglais
-Je vais lui demander
de garder la route.
Propos indistincts
-2 machines avant 1.
-Un bateau sans pavillon,
ça attire notre attention.
Il y aura une prise
de contact radio avec lui
pour demander pourquoi
il n'arbore pas de pavillon
et ensuite,
il y aura un compte-rendu fait
sur la conduite à tenir.
-Qu'est-ce que vous regardez ?
-L'alignement de la 12,7.
Avec l'étrave du navire en face.
Les tirs de police,
il faut être aligné sur l'étrave.
On commence des tirs à 500 m.
On va lui envoyer des avertissements
et au fur et à mesure,
on va se rapprocher :
500 m, 400 m, 300 m.
Jusqu'un tir au but
sur l'étrave du navire,
s'il ne veut pas s'arrêter
ou s'il n'est pas coopérant.
-Désignez un but fictif.
100 m sur l'avant du client.
12,7, bâbord.
En garde bâbord. 2-8-4.
-Nickel.
-12,7, but reconnu.
-But fictif reconnu.
100 m sur l'avant du client.
Dépointage vérifié.
Alerte !
Mise en garde à droite.
Tirs d'arrêt effectués.
100 m sur l'avant du client.
Fin de munitions.
*-Abri de porte de bordé
demande le vert
pour l'embarquement
de la deuxième rotation.
Brouhaha
Musique rock
...
-OK, reçu !
-Sur le côté bâbord.
On est en visu de l'autre équipe.
*Propos indistincts
J'envoie quelqu'un.
-Il est parti de Lorient
et il va à Crozon.
-OK.
-On vérifie qu'ils aient
rien caché de dangereux.
On va les palper dans une zone
qui sera sécurisée pour nous.
On a rassemblé une masse,
une barre en métal,
tout ce qui pourrait servir
à nous frapper,
pour éviter, s'ils se rebellent,
qu'ils aient de quoi nous blesser.
...
-Il a un couteau
dans sa poche de pantalon droite.
...
-OK.
OK.
-C'est en cours,
l'enquête de pavillon ?
-Yes.
-C'est une arme pour l'exercice.
Elle a été découverte.
Elle était en détention illégale.
On n'a pas la preuve qu'ils avaient
les documents pour la posséder.
Donc voilà.
Les couteaux,
les marins ont le droit d'en avoir,
mais on les retient provisoirement,
pour éviter...
C'est quand même dangereux.
Ca peut être aussi une menace.
On les garde quand même
en rétention provisoire.
...
-Alright.
-Un carton, trois ballots.
Musique calme
...
-Depuis plusieurs années,
la contestation du droit en mer
est en augmentation.
Pour les marins,
ces opérations de contrôle
sont fréquentes.
-Comment on a fait évoluer
les entraînements ?
-Par rapport aux conflits
qu'on rencontre,
à l'actualité,
au retour d'expérience
des opérations qu'on conduit.
On cherche à mettre nos mains
dans des situations basiques.
On recherche le drill,
les actions fondamentales
qu'ils doivent connaître.
Au combat,
ce sont ces fondamentaux
et ces réflexes pavloviens
qui vont faire que l'action
sera efficace.
Et on les mettra
en situation d'inconfort.
Puis...
on les met face
à des cas non conformes.
Tout type de situation.
Brouhaha
Musique de tension
...
-La frégate est le bâtiment
le plus déployé en haute mer.
Alors la marine nationale a
entièrement renouvelé sa flotte
de frégates multimissions
capables de naviguer
en autonomie
sous toutes les latitudes.
Olivier a connu
les longues traversées
et les anciens bateaux,
moins confortables.
-Bienvenue chez moi.
Ici, on va retrouver mon poste.
C'est là où les marins vont avoir
leur espace personnel
et vont se reposer.
Ici, on retrouve une bannette,
seul espace d'intimité
à bord.
On va pouvoir
un peu se retrouver,
quand on est en mission
et longtemps en mer.
-Où vont vos affaires ?
-Ici, on va retrouver
nos caissons de rangement.
-On appelle ça un caisson ?
-Exactement.
-Ca fait pas beaucoup.
-C'est vrai, mais on a l'habitude
d'optimiser, dans la marine.
-Combien de jours de mer un marin
peut-il naviguer dans une année ?
-Ca dépend. C'est particulier
pour ce bâtiment-là.
On va retrouver deux équipages
qui vont se relayer toute l'année.
On va prendre le bateau
6 mois dans l'année.
6 mois, on va être à terre,
et 6 mois, on sera sur le bateau.
Généralement, l'équipage
qui a le bateau va être en mer
la plupart du temps.
-C'est un bateau
plutôt confortable ?
-Oui, on a une vraie plu-value
par rapport aux anciens bateaux.
...
Propos indistincts
-Le 0 à 4, c'est quand on prend
le quart de 00h à 4h du matin.
Il faut soit avoir
une bonne vie intérieure
ou une bonne équipe,
parce qu'il faut pas s'endormir.
Et moi, c'était l'envie d'aventure
qui m'a surtout bougé.
J'avais pas envie
de me retrouver dans un bureau.
Dans la vie,
je suis un grand rêveur.
J'avais un peu envie de me dire
que j'ai aussi un peu vécu,
pas que dans mes rêves,
mais en vrai,
des choses incroyables.
J'avais envie d'être utile,
d'avoir un métier avec du sens.
Et aujourd'hui,
comme les conflits reviennent,
il y a vraiment des risques
et il faut en être conscient
pour aller au bout de la mission.
Ce pour quoi on a signé,
c'est aller au bout de la mission.
...
*"I Get Around", Beach Boys
-On a le clairon,
mais en soi,
mettre une musique personnalisée,
c'est pas mal.
C'est pour l'ambiance
dans l'équipage,
que tout le monde
soit de bonne humeur le matin,
avec une bonne musique.
Good morning,
French Warship Aquitaine !
Tout de suite,
le point météo du jour.
Le ciel sera couvert avec un vent
*de secteur est modéré.
La mer sera peu agitée.
La visibilité sera bonne.
Vous sentez cette odeur de poudre ?
Figurez-vous que dès 8h
auront lieu des tirs de 12,7,
de 20 mm et de 76.
Ca va faire du bruit.
Have a nice day.
Thank you for your attention.
...
-La cible, tribord 35,
2 nautiques 5.
-Tribord 35.
-Latitude, 500 pieds.
-A la différence
de la guerre sur terre,
le combat en mer est souvent
hors de portée des caméras.
Pourtant,
la bataille navale n'a pas disparu.
Désormais, elle fait appel
à des technologies de pointe.
Pour conserver l'avantage,
une frégate doit posséder
les meilleurs systèmes de combat.
*-Ils sont pas agressifs,
mais le comportement peut changer.
S'attendre
à un comportement plus agressif.
A la prochaine passe,
on entamera directement
les warnings.
-Ici, on est au centre d'opérations.
C'est ce qui regroupe l'ensemble
des sensors à bord,
ce qui permettra
d'activer les systèmes d'armes,
que ce soit missiles, torpilles...
On va retrouver
tout ce qui est radars, sonars...
*-Etat des armes,
le 76 en veille normale,
ravitaillé de 70 HE.
L'aster, 7 missiles présents,
branché,
en veille normale.
-La frégate Aquitaine est équipée
des derniers sonars
mis en oeuvre
par la marine française.
Avec des capacités de détection
très, très bonnes.
On va voir très loin.
On va détecter
tout ce qu'il y a sous la mer.
On va le classifier
et dans le cas d'une menace,
on va l'engager.
-1, 0, Mike.
Fire as soon as possible.
Over.
-Dans l'action,
il faut réagir très vite,
être très concis et précis,
sinon, il suffit
d'une seconde d'inattention
pour créer la faute.
*Propos radio indistincts
-La frégate multimissions
est un bâtiment de combat
capable de se reconfigurer
en fonction de la mission.
Ce jour-là,
l'exercice n'a rien d'une fiction.
Si Brieuc est concentré,
c'est qu'il est évalué
et que les tirs sont bien réels.
-Attention !
-On va tirer
avec le 76 mm.
Donc au large de Belle-Ile.
L'Armée de terre nous donne
la position d'une cible.
*-1, 1, 1, 0, alpha.
For mission to commence
as soon as possible.
Propos indistincts
...
-Fin de couplage.
Toile dans l'axe.
-Tir interdit.
*-Fin de couplage.
Toile dans l'axe.
-Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe, là ?
-On a des petits problèmes
de communication avec les terriens.
Du coup, on a avorté la...
-...l'Aquitaine se représente.
-Voilà, il l'a dit.
On a avorté la séquence.
On va se retourner,
attendre d'être bien
en contact.
-Pourquoi il faut être
en contact avec eux ?
-Ils vont nous permettre
de recaler quand il y a
une mauvaise visibilité.
Si on n'a pas de contact avec le DLO
et avec celui
qui nous ordonne le feu,
on sait pas s'il y a
un danger à proximité,
on sait pas si c'est bon.
...
-Temps de vol, 38 secondes.
Ready.
-Reçu.
...
-Pour une salve 2 coups. Attention.
-Attention.
...
-Feu !
2 coups partis.
*-2 coups partis.
C'était pour prévenir.
...
-Salve, attention.
-On est dessus.
On passe à la salve d'efficacité,
4 coups.
-Feu.
*-4 coups perçus.
-Commandant de CPC,
toile dans l'axe.
Fin des émissions.
...
On a eu un tir trop long.
Donc on a corrigé le tir.
Là, on a envoyé
la salve d'efficacité
pour détruire l'objectif
qui a été détruit.
Mission accomplie.
Là, on dérobe à grande vitesse
pour se mettre à l'abri.
*-Tu fais le dérobement
jusqu'à être
en dehors de la FSA.
Ensuite, tu te mets...
Propos indistincts
-Si les marins ont intensifié
leur entraînement,
c'est que la perspective
d'un combat naval
n'est plus une simple hypothèse.
-Commandant.
-Oui ?
-On entend beaucoup qu'il faut
repenser le combat naval.
Pourquoi faut-il le repenser ?
-Depuis une trentaine d'années,
on s'entraîne
de façon très sérialisée
pour être sûr que les équipages ont
acquis les savoir-faire basiques.
C'est ce que nous sommes
en train de faire
dans le cadre du stage
de remise à niveau.
Maintenant, ça ne suffit plus.
Le réarmement des marines
internationales,
la guerre en Ukraine
font qu'il faut qu'on s'entraîne
à l'incertitude du combat.
D'où la modification et
la transformation de la préparation
des bâtiments qui se tournent
vers la préparation opérationnelle
haute intensité.
Il faut absolument
habituer les équipages
à penser et à prendre des risques
autrement,
et à gérer l'incertitude du combat.
Musique paisible
...
-Alors que la mer
et ses richesses sont convoitées,
les rapports de force
se multiplient au large.
Dans ce contexte,
les espaces maritimes ont repris
une importance stratégique.
Le clairon résonne.
-Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
-Il y a un homme à la mer.
Brouhaha
-Visuel.
Visuel. Alignement avec la bouée.
L'homme jaune devant la bouée.
...
-Il me montre avec son bras.
-190.
*-Homme à la mer.
...
-Bien.
Reçu !
Tout à gauche.
...
-Depuis ce tournage,
l'équipage de l'Aquitaine a rejoint
sa zone d'opération en mer Baltique,
une région redevenue
une zone de tension
sur la scène internationale.
Une mer froide,
coincée entre la Russie
et les Pays baltes.
-Est-ce qu'il respire ?
...
-A gauche 20. Venir au 25.
-La barre est 20 à gauche.
-Bien.
...
-2 machines avant 2.
-2 machines réglées avant 2.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...